this is East Africa the Great Rift
Valley a land in constant upheaval the
flamingos and baboons here at Lake
Bogoria live in harmony they share this
landscape and all it has lost
[Music]
they may not be compatible but in the
midst of a glorious bounty they can
afford to be indifferent in July after a
successful breeding season nearly four
million flamingos gather along the seams
of the Great Rift Valley they clog the
inlets and crowd the local residents
the baboon's who live here all year
round can't help to take notice of the
sheer numbers of new arrivals some
babblers have never seen this many
flamingos before
and some of them don't know how to
behave
there are so many birds at Bogoria that
they trip over each other in order to
escape baboons are meat eaters but this
is something unusual for baboons
choosing between fruits and flesh is a
simple matter for these newbies
until now such an orchestrated attack on
forming days has rarely been witnessed
or recorded the graceful wading birds
become a buffet of pink feathers and
crimson for the young have discovered a
new taste and they like it
perhaps this is nature's coldly in
different way of restoring balance
[Music]